this is the jocko underground podcast
number eight with echo charles and me
jaco willink
good evening echo good evening topic of
the day
is body language
and i i i there's a bunch of great
resources about this
there's an online college called fremont
college and they had a really kind of
nice i was looking more of just an
outline of things to talk about they had
a pretty simplistic one
so
as we know so that's kind of what i used
for for talking through this um
body language
constitutes more than 60 of what we
communicate that's what they said i've
heard it say 70
have you heard that 70. i've heard 70 i
think sarah armstrong told me
70
from
eye behavior
direction that you point your feet
uh all these different things reveal
what you're what you're really thinking
and we as people
benefit by being able to
read
this language a little bit more clearly
look you get we all naturally get the
we get the vibe
right
to use a parlance of modern parlance my
kids talk about the vibe a lot
i can get the vibe if you're if echo's
standing there with his arms crossed
i might get the vibe that maybe he's not
hearing what i'm saying
but it's it's a lot better to go a
little bit beyond the vibe and actually
be able to interpret a little bit more
directly what some of these things tend
to mean not guaranteed to mean because
you could have your arms crossed just
because you're cold right yeah sure but
they also could be an indicator so
here's a couple things we're going to go
through
eye behavior
eye behavior can be very telling and
again i'm taking this from this fremont
college stuff i'm kind of paraphrasing
and reading parts that i think are cool
when communicating with someone pay
attention to whether he or she makes
direct eye contact or looks away
you hear this one all the time inability
to make direct eye contact
can indicate boredom
disinterest or even deceit
meaning hey when someone doesn't look at
look at you that means they could be
lying
again
it's good to know that
it's also good to know that it doesn't
necessarily mean that they're lying it
could just mean that they're bored and
i'm i'm one of the worst
perpetrators
if someone's not if i'm not
if i'm bored with what you're saying i'm
not looking at you anymore i'm looking
somewhere else
i'm looking at my phone i'm looking at
the jiu jitsu mat whatever
dean went through a phase where when
dean would get if i didn't like pay
attention to him he would attack me yeah
that makes sense and it was really uh a
bummer because getting attacked by dean
is a bummer especially when you're
looking in the other direction because
you're bored with what you say
[Laughter]
so i had to i had to train myself
to pay attention it's good training yeah
good training
and you know what's weird is i
this is i don't know if this is good or
bad it's probably bad
might be good though
i am
if i don't know you i'm actually going
to pay more attention to you
if you know because i i'm going to give
you the benefit of that like hey i don't
really know you but if i know you you're
my friend and you're boring me are you
getting no mercy
[Laughter]
uh
dilated pupils
someone's someone's eyes get kind of
big
that means it's favorable
mm-hmm
you gotta be looking pretty close to see
those those
pupils dilate have you ever seen
anyone's pupils yes and notice them
being dilated i don't know but i've seen
them i've seen their eyes open up like
uh like and seen their pupils get bigger
yeah so i guess i have seen it
pupils dilate when cognitive effort
increases
so if someone's focused on someone or
something they like their pupils
automatically dilate
maybe that's why you've never noticed it
before because they're never dilated no
one's ever been interested in what
you're
saying uh
pupil dilation can be difficult to
detect that's probably why because i
know you're very interesting thanks a
person's blinking rate
blinking rate increases when people are
thinking
when they're more stressed so they start
getting stressed out they start blinking
blinking can also indicate lying
true
get that person that's blinking blinking
watch your kids yeah
kids kids kids have no ability to
camouflage like when they're lying you
know they just they just can't look at
you yeah so it's good it's good to use
your kids
as a
guideline
to start beginning to be able to spot
these things unless they're like psycho
kids unless they're psychosis so they'll
be like straight up effortfully almost
enjoying the lying or something like
that if yeah it seems like some kids
would be like that
bro that blinking
one
for whatever reason i pay attention to
blinking all the time not in any kind of
judgment or nothing but you're aware
yeah big time so where it came from was
when i first started making videos and
interviewing people not for the
interview part of it but for the editing
part of it so when you edit
and you want to convey a certain like
emotion or whatever and they're saying
something awesome and then they're if
they're blinking it ruins the whole clip
oh
so and this is where it would um this is
where it would reveal itself a lot of
the time not all the time is at the end
you know like and you do a really good
job on this i have no idea why but
[ __ ] you do the at the end once you
say something cool right and it's done
you're done talking
you will just look and keep looking
directly into the camera and not blink
right and you'll keep looking right so a
normal person would be like boom i'm
done so not only will i blink but i'll
like relax my body i'll look away i'll
do whatever i'm done with the take i
said what i said but you have that
trailing moment of a good two three
seconds which is the longest time by the
way for that in that context where
you'll just look and keep that same look
on your face or whatever without
blinking
i'm comfortable with silence yes that's
which i think is what it is because also
when i answer a question i when i get
done i'll just stop
and i don't feel the need to continue
explaining or talking or
i also don't mind just silence if i'm
thinking
if you ask me a question or i'm trying
to formulate an answer i'm trying to
tell you something and convey a message
and i get to a point where i'm not sure
where i'm gonna go
i don't just fill that space
with
um or ah or any of those things i'm good
with it just being quiet yeah
yeah that that makes sense to me that
seems to be the case now that you kind
of explain it
but when someone does start blinking
it can tell a whole different story not
necessarily like actually what they're
saying but maybe if they're saying one
thing
they it
can indicate that they're feeling at the
very least feeling a way different thing
for example
um and also you know when i like i said
i first started being really aware of it
when i started making videos with people
like interviewing right and then i
started editing it and trying to make it
into some dramatic promotion or whatever
um and then i started noticing it on
actual movies so like certain good
actors will use blinking in their
performance to indicate all these
different things and they'll do it
effectively like denzel washington does
really good like when he's like stressed
or whatever he's blinking when he's like
whatever and if you start to pay
attention to that it's like that added
detail with acting anyway it's that
added detail that really adds like this
you feel it more you know yeah and it's
weird because you feel it even though
you don't know it's happening like until
now now you're going to watch him be
like oh i see denzel he's blinking he's
stressed and that's working i feel it
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to
jockonunderground.com and subscribe and
we're doing this to mitigate our
reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better communications with us
strengthen this legion of troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and eighteen cents a month
and if you can't afford to support us we
can still support you just email
assistance
jacounderground.com
and we'll get you taken care of until
then
we will see you mobilized
underground